بعد الافطار وقبل السحور وقت ذهبي يمارس
فيه الكثير رياضات بعضها تنتشر في رمضان
فقط واخرى دخلت على الخط البادل وكره
الطائره بين
بساطه الطائره والبادل ينقسم محبو الرياضه
في رمضان نتابع هذه القصه
سرعان ما اصبح مضرب البادل الجزء الرئيسيا
من هوايه شباب تخلوا عن الكره الطائره في
رمضان
وجدبته ملاعب البادل الساحره التي انتشرت
بشكل لافت في الرياض
رياضه البادل جديده علينا يعني جاءت في
الاونه الاخيره
قوانينها سهله مقاربه للتنس بشكل اسهل
فيها متعه متعه اهتمت ممكن جربت معنا قبل
شوي اللي يفهم قوانينها بكل سهوله استمتع
فيها حقيقه كل لعبه لها اجواء وطقوسها لكن
انا بالنسبه لي اشوف لعبه البدل افضل
بكثير بالرغم من وجود ملاعب للطائره في
حدائق الاحيان مهيئه اكثر الا ان محب كره
الطائره وتحديدا في رمضان لا زالوا يحبون
اجوائها البسيطه القديمه وتحديدا المتمثله
في ملاعب ترابيه وسط الاحياء
الوضع هنا مختلف الاجواء الحماسيه
والتشجيع والبساطه هي التي تطفي طابعا
خاصا للكره الطائره تجمع مباراه الكره
الطائره ابناء الحي في مساحه واحده
العمر ليس مهما للتفاعل مع اي نقطه يحصدها
احد الفريقين كل شيء بسيط هنا ولا يخضع
لقوانين صارمه كما اللعبه البادل
اكثر شيء بسيط في الملعب هو لبس الحكم
لبسك كانك رايح دوام ولا رايح مناسبه
بينما اشوفك تتحكم في
صراحه واتفاجات كذا وجيت الملعب وانا
الحاكم الدولي هنا المتواجد كل يوم حكم
لكن عاد اليوم جينا بالزياره رسمي لعبه
الطائره مثل ما تشوفون لعبه ممتعه تجمع
الكبار والصغار لعبه رمضانيه زين واكثر ما
يقتلون فيها بالوقت هذا زين واكثر الملاعب
شوفوا هناك هناك كل الملاعب يعني مليانه
ما شاء الله تبارك الله هي من اخف الالعاب
وافضل الالعاب
بالرغم من حداثه ملاعب البادل وشكلها
الجذاب الا ان اجواء الكره الطائره لا
تزال تشكل روتينا رمضانيا لدى محبيها
فهل تاخذ البادل حصه اكبر من الكره
الطائره مستقبلا عبد المحسن الحربي يا
العربيه الرياض